online income generation is no longer as
challenging as it once was there are now
too many sources on the internet
it is quickly expanding into the sizable
Market with much potential Freelancers
are currently contributing over 1.4
trillion US dollars to the US economy as
per the upwork press release according
to 71 of Freelancers they've been able
to retract more work online during the
past few years as per business to
community in this video we'll help you
with the top websites to earn money and
how you can make some extra cash with
these websites in addition to requiring
minimal to no initial costs these
websites provide flexible scheduling and
remote working so if you want to put
your money goals into action and earn
some extra cash then this video is for
you in this video we'll go through some
websites that can help you make money
online so if you're interested in making
money online then please leave a comment
below now let's go ahead and discuss
some of the top websites to earn money
online so first in our list we have
upwork upwork is one of the legitimate
money making websites that provide you
with the required tools to earn money
from home in the quickest and easiest
method possible it is an online
Marketplace for Freelancers in a variety
of fields the website assists
Professionals in finding projects
communicating with clients and getting
paid
upwork has listed jobs in various
categories such as Writing customer
service sales and marketing accounting
web mobile and software development
design I.T and networking and many more
now let's have a look at pricing upwork
takes 20 of the first 500 that you are
charging to the client as a commission
however ten percent if your client pays
you a total of more than 500 but less
than ten thousand so this was all about
upwork now let's go ahead and have a
look at the next website which is
virtual
virtual is a privately held American
Business that offers virtual assistant
services to business owners
professionals and small teams with a
location in San Francisco California
Virtual has its main office in Las Vegas
Nevada
for administrative work virtual sends
virtual assistants to serve various
clients in their time zone however each
client deals with a single devoted
assistant
virtual assistants carry out tasks
including replying to emails setting up
appointments and meetings doing product
research and placing orders
virtual.com employs remote assistance
for their service which is where the
opportunity to earn extra money occurs
virtual.com's job section may be found
at virtual.com forward slash jobs
their average earning per hour is
between 13 and 18 per hour depending on
client mix and utilization
now let's talk about the pricing the
hourly rate at search will ranges from
about ten dollars for an assistant to
34.47 for a consultant
the typical virtual compensation per
month ranges from about three thousand
and ninety eight dollars for executive
assistant to three thousand two hundred
and forty dollars for virtual assistant
next up we have Fiverr Fiverr is a
freelance website that advertises expert
services such as voiceovers translations
social media posts and Logo designs for
various clients and sectors it is
referred to as a micro task website
where you can perform relatively quick
brief one-time activities that they
refer to as gigs not only that there are
various types of services that you can
provide on Fiverr for example voice over
digital marketing graphic design video
and animation programming articles logo
design and much more
now talking about pricing there is no
price to be on the platform and no
experience is technically required on
Fiverr if you have the skills then you
could become the seller and whatever you
will earn from your seller account you
can withdraw your funds to either your
PayPal account credit to your Fiverr
Revenue card or transfer the money to
your bank account so this is how you can
make money on Fiverr the next on our
list we have freelancer.com one of the
largest online marketplaces for
freelance writers and employers is
called freelancer.com it is one of the
largest online marketplaces for
freelance writers and employers to date
freelance writers on the website have
completed over 18 million tasks which
gives you an idea about how popular this
website is
freelancer.com provides various services
like web design mobile app development
logo design data entry article writing
WordPress and similarly more than 1800
plus skills
now coming to the next websites to earn
money online people per hour
people per hour is a freelance Network
founded in the United Kingdom that
connects small businesses with
Freelancers for project-based work if
you want to apply your skills in one of
the numerous categories you can also
hire contractors and utilize the site as
a source of extra Revenue
people per hour provide various services
like business digital marketing
marketing branding sales writing
translation and much more
so coming to the pricing part people per
hour charges a service fee per client
for Freelancers the freelance website
charges a 20 service fee on revenues of
350 dollars
fortunately as you work more your charge
will reduce so here's a question for you
guys and you can give me your answer in
the chat section what according to you
is the best freelancing job let us know
in the comments alright so next on our
list is crypto jobs list
crypto jobs list is an online job board
for blockchain related positions
employers can use the site to search for
and connect with candidates for job
openings
candidates can look for jobs by keywords
location job title and firm name
developer marketer Trader and engineer
are popular job categories crypto jobs
lists provide jobs in crypto HR
blockchain HR and recruiting remote jobs
ethereum jobs Bitcoin jobs crypto mining
Etc so if you have the required skills
go for it
now coming to its pricing the average
yearly crypto salary is 91
432 US dollars
salary estimates are based on Anonymous
submissions from cryptos and website
users like you as well as data from past
and current job postings
now coming to the next website to earn
money online just answer
just answer is a free online question
and answer service that links customers
with subject matter experts you can ask
a question and receive a typed response
once you've been connected with an
expert you can chat with an expert over
the phone for an extra cost
in just answer you will find verified
experts in various Fields like taxes law
mechanics medical veterinary medicine
electrical work Plumbing Home
Improvement and much more the average
salary that you can earn from just
answer is two thousand to seven thousand
dollars
the experts can get their money through
PayPal hyper wallet and you can receive
your earnings at the end of the month
next is try my UI try my ui.com is a
remote usability testing platform that
provides cost-effective cross-platform
services for testing and improving user
experiences people from the Target
demographic submit narrated video
feedback as well as written survey
responses
apply the test site just as you would in
real life situations and communicate
your thoughts and difficulties allowed
so that the website developers can
benefit from your experience
to become a tester first register on the
website and then take an online test
using a screen recorder if you are
accepted by the company then you may
apply for any exam that becomes
available and begin earning money
try my UI only pays its testers via
Paypal the normal charge for each
completed test is ten dollars
when the tests are accepted the money is
deposited into the testers account
try my ui.com contest live websites
mobile websites mobile apps beta sites
Hi-Fi or Lo-Fi prototypes Android apks
Etc
now coming to the next website munchie
munchie is the headquarters for internet
marketing items that are due to be
introduced or have previously been
released in the market its mission is to
link creators and promoters in other
words it is a Marketplace for those who
introduced new items and Affiliates who
promote them it serves as a launch
calendar for all products that will be
released on websites like jvzoo and
Warrior plus munchie is a platform where
a bunch of people that are experts in
their field like software e-commerce or
digital products they all have a launch
period in this launch period everyone in
the industry will promote one product
pricing there are three groups of people
who can make money on munchie digital
product creators Affiliates and Munch
eyes owners
the developers of digital products
either build their own personal website
and affiliate program with it or they
make it and list it on jvzoo ClickBank
Warrior plus among other sites they
provide potential affiliate marketers
with early bird discounts and even free
access to certain products as a reward
then there are Affiliates who watch the
products on this site select the
relevant products which they wish to
promote and earn from it
then we have Munch eye owners they
essentially sell advertising space on
the website because it is so well liked
and a lot of product owners want to put
their things there in order to attract
additional affiliates
my pick my pick is a print Marketplace
that enables billions of people to sell
their original art prints clothing and
other things created from the images on
their camera roll through this website
users can transform their love of Art
and photography into luxury
print-on-demand products that earn the
money for nothing
artists designers and photographers can
use the mypick app and website to create
stunning custom framed prints pillows
phone covers t-shirts and even peel and
stick wallpaper using their photos
to start with my pick simply download
the mypick app and share with the world
your best photos
then anyone visiting mypick.com can buy
your photographs as high-end merchandise
for art fashion and lifestyle the
image's quality may result in a sale
rather than the number of images that
you upload now let's look at its pricing
a commission charge will be transferred
directly to your mypick wallet every
commission is based on the item that was
purchased your commission will be paid
out after you choose to withdraw from
PayPal so these were some of the top
websites to earn money online you can
give it a shot by trying any of these
websites which one of these websites do
you like the most let us know in the
comments below with that we've come to
the end of this video if you like the
video then please give it a thumbs up I
really hope that it helped you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
foreign
[Music]